- Le commandant taliban
Abdel Haq Fadi et ses hommes
redoutaient ce genre
de points de contrôle.
Avant de renverser
le gouvernement, ils menaient
des opérations d'assassinats
contre ses dirigeants,
ceux que le commandant appelle
les corrompus. Ils avaient
beaucoup de succès, dit-il.
ABDEL HAQ FADI, commandant unité
de renseignement des talibans
- "Je menais des opérations
clandestines. Nous allions
de place en place à la chasse
des personnes corrompues,
les pires des personnes pour les
assassiner. Nous quittions les
lieux à toute vitesse en portant
des vêtements de civils. Nous
avions des caches pour nos armes
dans nos voitures. Parfois, nous
assassinions avec un pistolet,
parfois avec une AK-47."
- Aujourd'hui, c'est au vu
et au su de tous qu'ils sont
à la recherche de trafiquants
de drogue. C'est le genre
d'opérations auxquelles
se consacrent maintenant
les talibans pour redonner
aux Afghans un sentiment de
sécurité, affirme le commandant.
- "Dans le passé, personne
ne pouvait aller au marché
le soir à cause des voleurs,
surtout à Kaboul.
La sécurité était très mauvaise.
Mais depuis que nous gouvernons,
en moins de deux mois,
grâce à Dieu, le nombre
de voleurs a diminué."
- C'est bien ce qui empêche
Maryam de fermer l'oeil depuis
deux mois. Pour sa protection,
nous avons changé son nom.
La jeune femme était juge
à la cour suprême, un rôle
qui lui valait déjà des menaces
sous l'ancien régime, celles
d'un homme en particulier,
un dirigeant taliban
qu'elle a condamné pour
violences conjugales.
- "J'étais suivie quand je
sortais, parfois ils prenaient
ma photo en faisant des courses
au marché et me l'envoyaient
à la maison avec un message.
Ils disaient : 'Nous sommes
tout près, plus près encore
que la veine de ton cou. Si tu
te retournes, tu nous verras.
Laisse tomber cette affaire,
une femme n'est rien pour nous,
juste un instrument. Ça ne vaut
pas le coût d'envoyer
notre leader en prison
pour une femme.'"
- Quand les talibans se sont
emparés de Kaboul et libérés
les prisonniers, son univers
tout entier s'est écroulé.
Les menaces ont repris par
textos et appels téléphoniques.
Depuis, elle mène une existence
de recluse. Tous les deux jours,
elle doit trouver un nouveau
refuge pour se soustraire
à ceux qui la menacent.
Déjà, elle a échappé une fois
à la mort de justesse.
- "Trois jours après la chute
de Kaboul, je me suis mise
en sécurité chez mon oncle.
Il était 8 h le soir,
je mangeais mon souper quand
ils ont lancé leur opération.
Il y avait envrion 50 talibans
avec des armes lourdes
et légères. J'ai les images
de la scène sur mon téléphone.
La maison entière a été abîmée,
six membres d'une famille
de voisins qui habitaient
au rez-de-chaussée sont morts."
- Nilufar, un nom d'emprunt
ici aussi, vit terrée dans la
crainte d'être découverte. Comme
procureur pour la Direction
Nationale de la Sécurité, c'est
elle qui devait présenter aux
juges des éléments de preuves
convaincants contre des membres
des talibans, de Daesh
et d'autres groupes terroristes.
- "Maintenant, ce sont eux qui
sont juges, qui sont procureurs,
avocats. Ils punissent les
criminels à leur guise et ils le
font sans se soucier du droit,
de la justice. Ce sont des
criminels qui nous punissent,
nos rêves sont anéantis."
- Les talibans comme juges,
jurys et bourreaux, c'est
ce qui est arrivé à leur fils,
raconte cette famille qui
souhaite témoigner anonymement.
Appelons-le Omar. Il avait
22 ans et il a été capturé
en pleine rue par des talibans
qui l'ont accusé d'un vol
qui se déroulait tout près.
Son cousin, qui était avec lui,
a prévenu son oncle, qui
aussitôt a cherché dans
quel commissariat de police
on l'avait emmené. Cet ancien
interprète de l'armée américaine
a frappé à plusieurs portes
avant de retrouver son corps
inanimé à même le pavé.
- "Ils l'ont tiré une trentaine
de fois au visage, à la
poitrine, dans le bras. Contre
un mur. Et son corps était dans
la rue, il gisait par terre.
Ils l'ont tué, les enfoirés.
Quand nous l'avons ramené à la
maison, j'ai pris sa tête dans
mes bras et j'avais des morceaux
de son cerveau dans mes mains."
- Ziak affirme que les talibans
ont par la suite fabriqué toute
une histoire pour le faire
passer pour un criminel,
mais qu'au fond, s'ils ont
criblé le corps de son neveu
de balles, c'est simplement
parce qu'il est de la vallée
du Panshir, une région qui
résiste au pouvoir des talibans.
- "Ils ont raconté toutes sortes
de conneries sur lui pour
se couvrir. C'est inutile
de se plaindre, en fait.
À qui peut-on se plaindre?
Ils vont tous nous capturer."
- Ziak croit que s'ils
n'arrivent pas à fuir
l'Afghanistan, sa famille
et lui sont condamnés
à subir le même sort.
Les Talibans continuent
d'affirmer que ceux qui ont
collaboré avec le précédent
gouvernement et les forces
étrangères n'ont rien
à craindre, qu'ils bénéficient
d'une amnistie, ce qui inclut
les femmes juges et avocates.
Des paroles qui ne rassurent
en rien la procureure Nilufar
et la juge Maryam.
- "Comment peut-on contempler
l'avenir? Nous luttons pour
survivre, sans aucun appui.
Nos comptes bancaires sont
gelés, nous avons peur
d'être tués par les Talibans
et, parfois, on se dit que
s'ils ne nous tuent pas,
c'est autre chose qui le fera.
La situation économique
nous tuera, c'est sûr."
- Elles ont cru bâtir un pays
plus juste pour elles et leurs
concitoyennes. Mais aujourd'hui,
si Maryam et Nilufar sont
toujours en vie, elles se
sentent complètement dérobées de
tout espoir. Le corps subsiste,
mais l'âme n'y est plus.
Par ailleurs, les informations
personnelles de près de 200
Afghans qui cherchent à fuir
le régime taliban ont récemment
été divulgués par erreur.
Leur adresse courriel et, dans
certains cas, leur photo se sont
retrouvées dans des courriels
envoyés par le ministère de
l'Immigration, des Réfugiés et
de la Citoyenneté.
Certains d'entre eux craignent
que d'autres informations, comme
des documents d'identité ou des
numéros de téléphone, ne soient
désormais entre les mains des
talibans. C'est le cas d'un
travailleur humanitaire qui dit
avoir reçu des menaces
téléphoniques.